well andy jones is the owner of jones
and sons in east london and joins me now
hello to you andy i wonder what you made
of those words from dr jenny harry's
today
urging people to to avoid those
unnecessary social contacts
well i'm getting the feeling that we've
seen this film before huh
it's extremely frustrating that the
doctor makes such a sweeping statement
which is great for her she gets a bit of
airtime that's great
but you're putting millions of people in
the hospitality sector on red alert now
are people aware of the year that we
have had in hospitality are people aware
of how tough it's been
all people aware that people have left
our industry good hard-working staff
have left our industry and they will
never come back it has made this year
almost unbearable we look forward to
christmas
every hospitality owner every
hospitality worker if it's something you
love to do you look forward to christmas
it's the best time of year it's amazing
as an owner this season is through until
march this pays the bills until march
this fills the holes that the first few
lockdowns have created for us and for
someone to make a statement that just
puts everybody on read aloud alert
i think
i think it's appalling behavior now
there's 22 cases nine from one single
event i don't think there's enough
evidence for dr harris to come out and
say something so sweeping that can have
a massive impact on our industry i think
it's really really irresponsible i mean
we the point is the government's trying
to get ahead of this so we don't see
another wave of this isn't it and and
that in itself would protect the
hospitality sector and the economy more
more broadly but we did then hear from
the prime minister uh this afternoon
saying christmas parties shouldn't be
cancelled at this point are you though
andy seeing people start to cancel
bookings since the news of the omicron
variant came out
we're not yet but let's not forget what
boris was saying at this time last year
christmas wouldn't be cancelled and then
let's see what happens okay we cannot
trust what boris johnson is saying to us
in the hospitality sector because he has
lied he has gone back on his word so
many times that i personally don't even
listen to a word he says now when you
contacted me today i was like here we go
again now the bigger companies that we
have booked in for christmas they will
have covid protocols now these are big
companies that will book my restaurant
or my studio space for the entire day
which is really you know i need that for
my business they will have kobe
protocols they will now be having
meetings tomorrow about cancelling their
huge christmas parties of 100 people 120
people 160 people this is the reality of
what's going to happen one sweeping
statement now you can get ahead of it
all you like you can roll out these
boosters all you like but the
scaremongering has now begun for the
hospitality sector and it's gonna have
an impact and it will be relatively
immediate for 22 cases nine of them from
one single event and i'm led to believe
not a single person in hospital
tell me that's fair for an entire
industry the third or fourth biggest
employer in the entire country the
hospitality sector it will be wiped out
yeah and obviously christmas a key
trading period it isn't just the
government though that is issuing these
warnings is it it's coming from the
world health organization as well this
is is coming from other countries who
are even putting the uk on the red list
and can i ask you though about the mask
mandate uh hospitality pubs and
restaurants
exempt from that mass mandate at the
moment
if it were to come into place that masks
needed to be worn when people were
moving around
pubs and restaurants what impact would
that have andy
if they allowed us to trade and put
masks on that is fine we are used to
that
it's very hard to enforce if people have
got a few drinks inside them it's very
hard to enforce
but i would go along with it if we could
stay open and it didn't deter people
from coming in we can't do another you
can only eat outside again it's way too
cold and it's just not the right time of
year for anything like that we have to
get through this period i think more
evidence is needed before statements
from the doctor can can implement an
entire industry and people's thinking on
that entire industry it's frustrating
and i've been on with you guys a few
times and you feel like i'm saying the
same thing
but i am saying the same thing we're
nearly two years into this
when are we gonna learn to live with
this when are we gonna learn that this
is now a part of modern day life like
wearing a mask wear a mask if you want
to don't wear a mask if you don't want
to i'm not judging jura on that but if
you want to come into hospitality places
if you want to have a good time don't
listen to the words of one doctor who's
got here time today with a sweeping
statement that's now put everybody on
the back foot and kee and i'm putting
the hospitality sector again in the
public eye are we gonna go are we not
gonna go if another lockdown comes it
will be catastrophic and we've heard
boris say this before
a few times and he went back in his word
and i can't imagine that he's going to
stick to it this time
i mean he did repeat again today didn't
he that he thinks that a lockdown like
we've seen before
isn't going to happen but but you are
not alone in feeling a sense of deja vu
andy um
nicola sturgeon has today suggested that
anyone who's going out anywhere and
mixing with anyone not within their
household should take lateral flow tests
on every occasion
do you think that is a possibility and
what impact would that then have on
business
it's an impracticality to take a lateral
flow test every time you go and see a
friend
we're in east london it's a very
sociable place there's lots of bars lots
of restaurants
people go out all the time we're a busy
restaurant you can't be asking people to
have a laugh flow test every time they
come in you can't be asking for a
vaccine passport you can't be asking for
evidence if they're you know if they've
had their booster when is this going to
end i don't listen to nicolas sturgeon i
don't necessarily listen to boris
johnson anymore it just feels like the
merry-go-round of the same thing is
happening and the hospitality industry
the arts will be affected of course
creative industries will be affected of
course but i'm speaking hospitality this
is going to have a massive knock-on
effect and the more people that start
shouting out about you need to do this
you need to do that you need lateral
flows just to go and see a friend people
aren't gonna bother they're gonna stay
in they're gonna watch television and
our industry is gonna get hit again we
were close for eight months by nearly
eight months in two years if that
happens again this is insane i'm in
london i paid london rent you cannot
continue to do this and stay in business
it's ludicrous we have to get on with it
yeah and i can hear that that sense of
dread in your voice andy and we wish you
all the best
for the christmas period andy jones
thank you very much indeed
thank you